ăn bánh mì Việt Nam Theo người nước ngoài
vào đây mình xếp hàng luôn á
ôi cô ta với em Hằng á đang đi đến cái phố này là phố háo
cá mà thấy á
khách du lịch xếp hàng
siêu đông luôn ở cái quán bánh mì này
nhưng mà vào đây bọn mình cũng chưa thử bao giờ
ê cảm giác càng lúc nó càng đông ấy
chị chị bị ờ tí hon so với những con người nước ngoài ấy
bạn ấy bảo là phải xếp hàng để lấy số mới Ra được
ở cuối hàng luôn
ô bạn nhân viên bảo là maybe là chờ 20 phút chị nhá
nhưng mà mình đã có menu
trong này có six Nature là bánh mì heo quay
45 k và bánh mì 10 cẩm PA tê xà xíu 45 k
mình sẽ gọi thử 2 cái signature xem SAO
siêu đông luôn
cảm giác như là á mình là người không phải cảm giác sự thật
mình là người thấp nhất ở đây
Xin lỗi chị nhà em đã hết đăng hết các loại mất rồi
thế đổi sang cái gì được hả em
có chỗ ngồi nha bây giờ bọn mình sẽ sang
chỗ ngồi
7 giờ 10 mọi người order xong
bây giờ là 07:37 là bọn mình có bánh mì nha
là bao nhiêu phút nhở 2 7 phút
27 phút là sau khi order nha
mọi người chắc là cả xếp hàng rồi cả
order cái thời gian buổi tối này rất là đông ấy
tầm sang định tầm 40 phút
tại chia bên trong là cô ta mở Ra là thấy là có cà rốt nè
rồi cả các loại rau thơm
dưa chuột và đặc biệt là đây là cái bò áp chả
trông bò rất là nhiều nha à
thêm một miếng phô mai chia đờ nữa kìa
bò
quan
trọng là mình cảm giác cái phần bánh mì và cái phần nhân ấy
nó rất là sạch sẽ
nó gọn gàng ô kê
10 cẩm bên trong là cô ta thấy có lạp xưởng xà xíu cà rốt
dưa chuột và BA tê
bỏ
giòn hơn
đây các bình ngọt giá 45.000 mà cái chất lượng nó
sạch sẽ như thế này
thấy không
cái chất lượng mòn như này thì em thấy SAO nó mới đáng chứ
ô kê chứ mức độ là bầu trời hơi lâu